it's the world's biggest flying machine
airlander is larger than a Boeing 747
and 24 feet longer than the previous
titleholder the Antonov an-225 this
blimp like airship uses helium to get
off the ground but it uses its
aerodynamic shape to stay in the air it
can hover in the same spot for five days
straight and can land on sand water ice
or snow british aeronautics company
hybrid air vehicles developed the
original model for the u.s. army but the
program ran out of funding in 2013
several months later hybrid air bought
back the airlander project from the
military for 301 thousand dollars the
company plans to sell the massive
airship for 40 million dollars to oil
and mining companies that need to
transport cargo to remote parts of the
world the airlander has attracted some
unusual fans Bruce Dickinson lead singer
of the British heavy metal band Iron
Maiden has invested four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in the project he
wants to fly it non-stop around the
world and stream the trip over the
Internet
the air Landers maiden voyage is
scheduled for 2016
you